[Music]
meanwhile Paul Abdul is hit the road for
the first time in 25 years let me tell
you a little something about her cab
lady has still got it make no mistake
about that she proved it when she lit up
the lip-sync battle stage with one of
her biggest celebrity admirers Jenna
Dewan Tatum I had no idea the impact
that I had on Jenna
until Channing came up to me at an event
said dude straight up I'm not kidding
when I tell you this blind is that
planned because my wife it's like you're
the reason she's in the business it's
because I've always wanted to be you and
do cold-hearted snake
[Applause]
and then smash cut to a couple months
later and I got to work with her
[Applause]
yeah that lip sync battle surprise was
all Jenna's idea but what's crazy is
Jenna's 36 Halle is 54 and they look and
dance like they could be sisters she
said it on the show how she freaked out
she was it she was actually dancing me
plus she's incredible
I just she's a bright light Gina's not
the only one fangirling all over Paula
[Music]
since the former Laker girl got her
start in the mid 80s as Janet Jackson's
choreographer three generations loved
the songs those moves and little girls
love her fashions
now let's break down Paula's total
package tour by the numbers she has for
costume changes she performs six of her
hits Paula along with the new kids on
the block and boys two men are hitting
up 45 cities and as for the fans well
she did have this one shocking moment
there's a part where I can go out to the
mosh pit area and can really connecting
with fans they're having phone
conversations while I'm singing for
every girl and I can't have these
numbers it's the character they're
asking me questions
we're googling you can't believe your
age item sorry I'm like forever your
girl I got to go let me tell you nobody
rocks the bodysuit like Paula Abdul I
saw all of this firsthand Friday night
at the Hollywood Bowl Paula invited me
to come to the show and she was great
she never stopped dancing at the crowd
loved her so I say welcome back home
[Music]
you